I got this in last night the state of
Nevada is trying to pass a referendum
where state and local government
employees cannot have moustaches is
anyone seeing this prop 5 5 1 there take
away those testers that ain't fair
they will take my moustache from my cold
dead upper left my friend no no I am
coming into work without Saturday yeah
you will more with that mustache hell
yeah it's my daddy's moustache or he had
a similar I don't want to work here
without a moustache I really don't I
don't want to work here either well you
have a very light must I have so lucky
you it's time for a bleep chain hoist
Sheriff's Department run don't run
sir I wonder if we could take a moment
of your time today her the the state
government is trying to pass a bill to
my god oh no oh no the state government
would like us to do is they they're
trying to require us to perform our job
right mustache lists my stache yes
without your mustache the aid of
moustaches and we're trying to get 2,000
signatures here on this - eh why do they
know why don't they like the mustache
sir
I'll probably tell them beard or ass
yeah why I think I know why was that cuz
you look like gigolos with moustaches it
looks like paid male companions I can
sign do you have like on it maybe caller
what's your name sir Larrie plum vo um
Larrie plum la double r i IE yeah Larry
say Larry with an IE yeah same
pronunciation well we had two Larry's in
the family so they wanna do what I wanna
eat
yeah sure see Larry initial next to your
signature there sure what am i signing
now thank you we're good thank you well
good luck to you in your chosen field
Sheriff's Department is trying to take
away our moustaches
deputies and we're getting a petition
together to see if we can hold on to
them for a little while so if you
wouldn't mind putting your John Henry on
there do us a big favor
wait what we want you to sign this
petition we're trying to keep our
moustaches they're trying to take them
to life you could just go which our old
John Williams on there that really
doesn't make any sense kind of the same
things just completely stupid yeah I
don't I don't necessarily I mean you
guys look like a bunch of a butt darts I
think it'd be a FRA look like butt darts
we need members of the community to help
us out my son in this petition if you'd
sign it tonight that'll let us keep our
moustaches which will let us keep you
safe so we'd appreciate your signatures
than that we sign our character names
sure go ahead
what's our opinion on the department
banning moustaches check out the action
on these you can't tell whether I'm
smiling or I'm hangry when I do that hmm
poker face huh I think you got my going
for my gun
mm-hmm my lips not telling you oh where
am I going on my kill window mmm gun
nice that's my girl hug yeah I'm not
gonna choke yep just ain't saying and
with this
forget it think it bluffed me with us
too am i mad at you holding right now
am I about to help you find the Arby's
you don't know
I'll say I admire your conviction
turning down your badge and gun keeps
them a wild dogs away from you
you